This is Support Engineering Weekly from the Support Engineering Blog. Technical conversations for engineers who troubleshoot, support, and operate Microsoft technologies.
Imagine, right, you're walking into your living room, you flip the light switch on the wall, and instead of the lamp turning on, your neighbor's garage door randomly opens.
Oh, and your toaster instantly catches on fire.
Right. Yes, exactly. Your toaster just spontaneously combusts. I mean, in the real physical world, you would probably call an exorcist.
You just run.
Yeah.
But you know, in the world of enterprise cloud architecture, they just call that a Tuesday.
They really do, and that is the exact chaotic reality we are getting into today. So, welcome to the deep dive.
Glad to be here.
Today, we are exploring a highly detailed, honestly, incredibly revealing stack of internal Microsoft service health and Message Center reports, and we're looking at a very specific window of time here: August 24th through August 28th, 2026.
Yeah, and just to set the stage for you listening, this isn't going to be like a dry list of tech outages or server logs.
Oh, absolutely not. We are going to treat this stack of reports like a forensic investigation.
Exactly. Because our mission today is to decode the hidden mechanisms of why things actually break in modern cloud platforms.
Right. Uncovering the invisible, deeply interconnected dominoes of enterprise architecture. Because, well, whether you are an IT administrator whose literal job is keeping the lights on, or—
Or you're just a professional sitting at your desk, you know, wondering why your Teams app is suddenly acting like it's possessed.
Exactly. Understanding these hidden dependencies is the ultimate shortcut to being well-informed about the digital tools you rely on every single day.
It really is. When you—uh, when you pull back the curtain on a platform like Microsoft 365, you start to realize that what looks like a single cohesive application on your screen—
Right, like just a standard app.
Yeah, it's actually this massive breathing ecosystem of microservices, identity claims, and, well, hidden data pipelines.
Okay, let's unpack that ecosystem, because the first major incident from the reports perfectly illustrates this. It's what I call "the illusion of the front end."
Oh, yeah. We always tend to assume that where we see the problem is where the problem actually lives.
Right. But on August 27th and 28th, users ran into these massive walls with Microsoft Teams channels.
Ah, the infamous Power Automate bottleneck.
That's the one. Power Automate flows that were, uh, supposed to post automated messages into Teams channels just suddenly started failing.
Just completely stops working.
Yeah, and then cloud flows trying to post or reply with adaptive cards in Teams, those completely broke too. Users were getting hit with HTTP 429 or 500 errors.
The messages just vanished into the void.
Exactly. And naturally, if you're the user sitting there staring at your screen, you assume Microsoft Teams is broken.
Right, because the symptom is in Teams, so the blame goes to Teams. But, uh, what's fascinating here is what those specific errors actually mean.
Break that down for us.
So, an HTTP 429 error essentially means "too many requests." I mean, it's the digital equivalent of a bouncer at a club saying, you know, "the building is at capacity."
Right. Nobody else is getting in.
Nobody. And a 500 error, that's an internal server error, which is basically the server just throwing its hands up in a total panic. It literally cannot process what you're asking it to do.
Wow. And, you know, earlier you mentioned adaptive cards breaking. For anyone who isn't a developer, an adaptive card isn't just like a simple text message.
No, not at all.
It's those interactive mini-apps that pop up in a chat, right? Like, uh, an expense approval form where you can actually click "Approve" right inside the Teams channel.
Yeah, and that interactive element is crucial here. Because when Power Automate tries to publish one of those adaptive cards into a Teams channel, it isn't just one standalone program tossing a file to another.
It's way more complicated than that.
Way more. It relies on a highly specific internal service dependency to render the interface, process the data, and finally publish that card.
So it's a whole chain of events.
Exactly. In the old days of on-premises software, if the messaging app was broken, it meant the messaging server was down. But today, it's a web.
A massive web. And according to the incident report, there was this huge influx of service calls that completely exhausted the available resources in that specific dependency's infrastructure.
So Teams was totally fine.
Teams was not broken. The root cause had absolutely nothing to do with the Teams client.
The infrastructure holding up that specific, you know, invisible bridge between Power Automate and Teams just buckled under the weight of the traffic.
It's like—it's like yelling at the delivery driver on your porch because the restaurant's stove is broken.
Yes! That is a perfect analogy.
I mean, the symptom is standing right in front of you, but the actual failure is miles away in some back-end kitchen.
And that perfectly captures why troubleshooting in the cloud requires an entirely different mindset today. You really have to trace the complete dependency chain.
Because if an IT team just stared at the Teams admin console trying to fix this—
They'd be staring at it forever. You have to look past the app where the error surfaced and interrogate all those hidden services feeding it.
Okay, so if hidden dependencies are the engine, I think we have to ask what usually causes that engine to sputter in the first place?
Right, and you would assume it's like malicious attacks, hackers, or some old hardware catching fire.
Yeah, that's the classic assumption. But looking at this August 2026 window, the culprit is almost always, well, good intentions.
Routine changes meant to improve the system.
Exactly. The butterfly effect of routine software updates. Let me give you an example from the reports. Microsoft deployed an authorization configuration update, and it was meant to block users who didn't have active licenses.
Which makes total logical sense.
Right. Keep the unlicensed folks out of the system. But the update inadvertently locked out fully licensed, completely legitimate Teams users. Microsoft had to rapidly revert it.
Which really exposes the fragility of entitlement logic. I mean, a tiny miscalculation in how the system checks a user's subscription status suddenly cascades into, you know, thousands of people getting locked out of their morning meetings.
Just massive disruption from a tiny tweak. And then we have the SharePoint guest access incident.
Oh, that one was a mess.
Yeah. A newly deployed change interacted incredibly badly with something called the dynamic claims process. So these guest users who were already granted access via Microsoft 365 Groups were suddenly hitting this cold, dead AccessDenied.aspx page.
Just completely locked out.
Yeah. And the only workaround was for administrators to manually bypass the group and add those users directly to SharePoint members groups. So walk me through this. What actually is a dynamic claim? Because the users were definitely in the system.
Right. So think of permissions in layers, right? The user has an identity in the overarching directory.
Okay.
And they belong to a specific group. But that group membership doesn't just magically open the door to a specific SharePoint site.
It doesn't.
No. The overarching directory has to hand the user a digital token, a claim, that SharePoint specifically understands. And that translation happens dynamically, on the fly.
Oh, I see. So the directory is saying, "Hey, this person is cool," but SharePoint needs that translated into its own specific language.
Precisely. And Microsoft deployed a change that basically disrupted that dynamic translation.
So the identity was perfectly fine.
The identity was fine, the group was fine, the SharePoint site was fine, but that invisible translator sitting right in the middle completely broke down.
Wow. It's like the bouncer gave you a VIP wristband, but the bartender suddenly doesn't recognize the color.
Exactly.
But I want to push back on this for a second on how these things even make it into production. Let's look at another one: Microsoft Bookings.
Okay, yeah.
Users started seeing completely blank pages because of repeated timeouts from a deprecated KV cache lookup. Basically, they enabled a change to retire an old cache, and it took down the pages.
Right.
Now, if I'm an IT director looking at this, I'm thinking Microsoft is a massive tech giant with virtually unlimited resources.
Sure.
How does a cache update break a booking page? Don't they test this stuff in a sandbox before pushing it to millions of users?
Trust me, every IT leader screams that exact question when their systems go down. But to understand how a cache deprecation brings down a page, we have to talk about technical debt.
Okay, break that down for me.
First, a KV cache stands for a Key-Value cache. It is essentially a high-speed digital dictionary.
Okay.
The system looks up a simple key, like, say, a user ID, and quickly gets the complex value associated with it, like their scheduling preferences. Think of it like a coat check.
A coat check.
Yeah. You hand them a simple ticket, they hand you your heavy winter coat.
Okay, makes sense. So they decided to shut down an old coat check.
Right. They deprecated it, meaning they told the system, "Hey, we're retiring this, stop using it."
Okay.
But when you operate at the scale of Microsoft 365, you aren't just building new things. You have thousands of legacy APIs and older programs just kind of floating around.
So they didn't all get the memo.
Exactly. Just because you closed the coat check doesn't mean every old piece of software got the message.
So the old software is still standing in line trying to hand over its ticket.
And waiting.
Yeah.
And waiting. And if a legacy API is still hardwired to look for that old KV cache, and the cache obviously stops responding because of the deprecation update, the API triggers a timeout. It waits so long that eventually the end user just gets a completely blank screen.
Wow.
You can test a million scenarios in a sandbox, sure, but replicating the exact chaotic, legacy-entangled environment of the real, massive production world, it's nearly impossible.
It's akin to trying to replace the engine of a commercial jet while it's cruising at 30,000 feet.
Which perfectly explains why these seemingly minor adjustments cause such havoc.
Yeah, like the reports noted that virtual desktop users lost their optimized Teams experience because of a—get this—seemingly minor routing change.
Right.
And globally, OneNote on iOS had sign-in problems traced back to a single line of routing code being tweaked in a specific software build.
But notice the remediation strategy for almost every single one of these incidents in the reports.
Yeah, it was always rollback. Just reverting to the previous state.
Reverting to a previous known good state remains the single most effective survival strategy in cloud engineering.
Because you can't fix it live.
No. You do not try to hot-fix the complicated dynamic claims translator or the routing code while millions of users are actively locked out. You just roll the entire environment back to yesterday's configuration.
Okay, so if human oversight can't always catch the butterfly effect, and the front end lies to us about where the problem is—
Right.
We kind of have to rely on our administrative dashboards to tell us the truth.
Yeah, you would hope so.
But during this late August window, multiple administrative data services experienced severe reporting delays. We aren't even talking about the apps breaking here; we are talking about the monitoring tools breaking.
Ah, the telemetry mirage.
Here's where it gets really interesting.
This is perhaps the most insidious issue in the entire stack of reports, honestly.
Yeah. The reports show that Microsoft 365 Copilot usage and adoption data was delayed for users across North America and Europe. Huge delay. And the Microsoft 365 admin center, Viva Insights—which by the way includes Copilot readiness data and the adoption score reports—they all lagged days behind reality. And on top of that, a standard .NET service update introduced a code regression that completely froze the Microsoft 365 Apps device inventory update status.
So basically, the engine of the car is running perfectly fine, but the speedometer on the dashboard is jammed at zero.
Exactly. Let's put ourselves in the shoes of the listener for a second. If you are an IT director and you just spent, you know, millions of dollars of your annual budget buying Copilot licenses—
Oh, boy.
You have staked your annual bonus on this rollout. You log into your dashboard on a Thursday morning, and you see Copilot usage absolutely flatlining.
Zero growth.
Zero growth, zero adoption for days. A frozen dashboard isn't just a technical glitch in that moment; it is a full-blown career panic attack.
Completely.
How do you know if the tool is actually dead or if it's just the dashboard playing tricks on you?
If we connect this to the bigger picture, that panic really highlights a fundamental concept every modern professional needs to grasp.
What's that?
The distinction between service availability and data availability.
Okay, break that down. How are they different?
So, service availability means the tool itself is functioning.
Right.
Your employees can open Copilot, they can ask it to draft a complex project proposal, and it successfully generates that text. The actual workload is doing its job.
The tool works.
The tool works. But data availability means the telemetry pipeline is functioning.
The telemetry pipeline being—
The system that watches the user.
Exactly. The hidden nervous system. It watches the user draft the email, records that action, processes the analytics in the background, and eventually updates your administrative dashboard.
Oh, I see.
And they run on entirely different infrastructures.
Yeah.
In this specific incident, Microsoft identified an upstream component involved in report data access that just—it just stopped responding.
So the data was there, it just wasn't moving.
Right. The usage data was queuing up in a massive traffic jam, but it wasn't making it to the administrative user interface.
And the .NET update freezing the device inventory is another perfect example of that.
Exactly. The laptops and endpoints out in the real world were still downloading their security updates. They were perfectly safe.
But the admin center wasn't reflecting it.
Right, because a code regression severed the reporting link between the devices and the dashboard.
So the danger here isn't necessarily that the systems are down; the real danger is the human reaction to the stale data.
Operating off a telemetry mirage leads to disastrous operational decisions.
Like what?
Well, if you see Copilot usage flatlining and you don't check the underlying service health reports to confirm a known telemetry delay—
Mhm.
You might pause a multi-million-dollar training initiative.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, or you might send out an angry company-wide email demanding people use a tool they are literally already using.
Or worse, with the frozen device inventory.
Exactly. Support teams might start running aggressive troubleshooting scripts or even remote wipes on endpoint devices because the admin center says they are horribly out of date.
Oh, that's a nightmare.
They end up breaking perfectly healthy machines to fix a problem that only exists on a frozen dashboard. You must always validate report freshness before making a high-stakes decision.
That makes total sense. So what does this all mean? If humans can't keep up with this invisible complexity, and our dashboards can't always report it accurately, how on earth do we actually govern these systems?
That's the big question.
Because keeping these platforms compliant with international laws seems honestly mathematically impossible without an army of auditors. But Microsoft's answer to that is kind of tucked away in a major update from the Message Center reports.
Yeah, the AI-powered regulatory templates for Purview Compliance Manager.
Right. Tucked in the notes, Microsoft announces they are introducing a feature that uses artificial intelligence to take highly complex, dense regulatory PDF documents—
The kind written in deep legalese by government bodies, yeah.
Exactly. And it converts them directly into actionable IT controls and assessments within your network.
Literally translating the law into network configuration.
But the really interesting detail in the report is that the worldwide general availability for this feature was just pushed back. It was supposed to happen in August, but it's been delayed to early or mid-October 2026.
Which is telling. Pushing a release date for a core compliance tool usually indicates they are making absolutely sure the underlying translation engine is bulletproof.
Before unleashing it on enterprise governance data.
Exactly.
But I've got to ask: there is so much hype around AI right now.
Oh, definitely.
Every single tech company slaps "AI-powered" on their press releases. Is turning a PDF into an IT control actually a game changer, or is this just another shiny new button that looks great in a demo, but doesn't actually change how the IT department operates?
This raises an important question, but honestly, this is a massive paradigm shift. It points to a complete structural change in how enterprise environments will operate over the next decade.
Why is this so structurally different from what we do right now?
Consider how compliance has historically worked, right? A regulatory body in Europe passes a new data privacy standard.
Right, GDPR or something.
Exactly. An organization's legal team sits down and reads a 300-page PDF. Then they schedule a dozen meetings with the IT security architects.
Sounds exhausting already.
It is. Those humans manually translate the legal jargon into technical requirements. The lawyers say, "Section 4 requires strict data compartmentalization," and the IT team translates that into, "Okay, we need to enforce 90-day password rotations and encrypt this specific data silo."
So it's incredibly slow.
Slow, highly manual, and extremely prone to misinterpretation.
It's like a corporate game of telephone where the message gets distorted at every single step.
Exactly. But what this Purview update represents is a move away from that human-bottlenecked translation. The AI ingests the regulatory source material and directly maps it to operational controls.
Wow.
It is like having a legal translator that instantly rewrites the company rulebook, pushing the actual technical configurations directly into the system every time a judge bangs a gavel.
It really shows us that AI is moving past being just a generative novelty.
Yeah, it isn't just a chatbot you ask to write a polite email to your boss or summarize a long meeting anymore.
No, it is becoming a structural architect for corporate governance.
And the environment demands it. As we explored with those broken adaptive cards and the legacy KV caches, the cloud environment is just too interconnected, too complex, and changes far too rapidly for manual human oversight to catch everything.
So if the infrastructure is dynamic and invisible, the compliance mechanisms have to be equally dynamic and AI-driven.
Exactly.
Synthesizing everything we've pulled from this late August snapshot of the cloud, I think a very clear picture emerges for anyone navigating this space. The overarching theme is just invisible complexity.
Yeah, cloud infrastructure is a deeply interconnected web.
When you are trying to figure out why a shared link in Teams is broken, or why an automated workflow just vanished into thin air, you have to look past the immediate symptom.
The error message staring at you on your screen is rarely the root cause.
Right. And routine updates carry a massive butterfly effect. Tightening a simple authorization rule can accidentally lock out thousands of legitimate users.
Or retiring an old, forgotten cache can take down an entire Bookings page.
And crucially, we have to remember that our diagnostic dashboards can sometimes freeze while the engine is still running smoothly under the hood.
Trust your telemetry, but always, always verify its freshness.
Absolutely. Because whether you are troubleshooting a massive corporate network or just trying to navigate the digital tools for your own small business, you have to think about the layers beneath the surface.
You can't just look at the light switch on the wall.
No, you have to visualize the wiring hidden in the walls, the power lines down the street, and the entire grid feeding the city.
The modern professional really has to become a systems thinker.
Which leads me to one final thought I want you, our listener, to mull over as we wrap up today. It builds on everything we've explored.
Okay, let's hear it.
We know that hidden dependencies cause unpredictable, cascading failures. We know that routine, well-intentioned changes can break systems in really bizarre ways. And we know that administrative dashboards can utterly fail to report reality. Now, we are entering an era where our complex compliance rules are going to be written and deployed by AI, and our daily workflows are going to be managed by AI Copilots. So, what happens in a few years when an AI-generated configuration change breaks a hidden dependency that an AI-generated dashboard completely fails to notice?
Wow. The ultimate blind spot.
Right. Who fixes the machine when the machine doesn't even know it is broken? It makes that simple light switch look pretty good in comparison. Keep thinking on that, and keep looking beneath the surface. We'll catch you on the next deep dive.
You've been listening to Support Engineering Weekly from the Support Engineering Blog. For the full articles, references, and technical resources from today's discussion, visit the URL blog.sadhan.ch.